[Music]
it is my last night in Chicago I got to
tell you in four days I did everything
you can do here I ate well I drank a lot
in earlier this afternoon I beat the
Cubs 11:00 to 2:00
it's not that hard
you should try it it's fun I'm going to
miss Chicago Judah mission completely
yeah I leave here though with great
memories and an irrational hatred of the
Green Bay Packers that I do not
I hate those guys I don't even know why
yeah what is a packer anyway I don't
even know yeah
probably shouldn't think about it to
know we're talking about sports
oh wow what about sports news or some
big sports news the Los Angeles Kings
won the Stanley Cup and I don't you
heard about this the big victory parade
was today and man does LA go crazy when
they win this Stanley Cup take a look at
this real news footage this is actual
news footage there they are they won
they're on the bus they've got the cup
that's real footage and that was the
most exciting part of the parade this
town knows how to celebrate a team
you guys know speaking of Chicago one of
your own having a very difficult time in
LA did you hear this yesterday burglars
broke into Kanye West's home yeah yeah
as a result 500 marble statues of kanye
west are missing their nudes
all of them hey you wanna hear a crazy
Chicago story a Chicago woman is
planning to sue the police after she was
tasered despite being pregnant yeah
the woman is suing on behalf of her
newborn baby boy Zeus god of lightning
I love that one hey got some bad news
for any fans of the show Weeds I don't
know we have any fans the show Weeds
here but yeah showtime announced its
canceling the marijuana themed show
canceling it yeah fans of weeds were so
upset they almost did something
[Applause]
here's a weird fact true fact the city
with the highest per-capita consumption
of Twinkies is none other than you
guessed it Chicago Chicago yeah yeah the
study appeared in the latest issue of no
[ __ ] Sherlock Magazine
you